all right joining us now a Steelers
running back James Connor who's being
made available to us today on behalf of
the Polaris slingshot three-wheeled
roadster and it's summer of fun test
drive program that will send consumers
to Hawaii Polaris slingshot is also
behind the July 16 national stick-shift
Day James Conner can you drive a stick
shift I can't I look forward to even
learn how to how to drive it even better
you know if you go to the logo
dealership actually they'll attack and
do a test drive they'll teach you how to
drive it and everything so yeah I got
some work to do on it but I want some
hard to learn a lot to learn I was so
you know how you just need a refresher
need a refresher
I need a refresher because my well my
good friends from back in the day
actually had a Jeep that would state
shift and he took me around named Sean
he took me around in the parking lot of
a tea party line and taught me how to
drive a stick so I just need a refresher
yeah I tell you what I've had a few cars
with stick shifts and every time I get a
new one you need that refresher so you
know how to do it hey I was telling you
before we started we last spoke before
you were drafted by the Pittsburgh
Steelers you got two years now in the
NFL
give me something about the NFL that is
easier than you thought it was going to
be and something about it that is harder
than you thought it was going to be
good question something easier than a
thought on none of it is easy I just
think that it's easier to stay focused
because you know when you're in college
you have a lot of other obligations but
with an NFL it's obviously just that's
your job is full-time so and I took a
lot of obligations but you know all your
time is focused to getting better and
doing something tours towards football
so you know it's not like college we got
your schoolwork and kind of balance
other things and so on but what I also
learned about it is is uh you know with
time and experience you would you get
bigger and stronger and you adapt as the
game changes too so uh you know uh you
know I'm knockin compete so you just
change with the game we had an
opportunity to prove yourself last year
and prove yourself you did what are you
working on to get better at in 2019 you
just cover all the basics again you do
what got you there and you just do it a
little more urgency and do it a little
more passion I'll stick to the basics
let's work a little harder every year
you know just try to cover all areas as
I run it back in at the teammate and so
on you know so it's easy just it's work
a little harder James I'm a firm
believer that all the stuff that's gone
on over the past five or six months and
we don't need to rehash at all we know
there's been plenty of stuff then all of
that is going to result in bringing the
team closer together it's gonna motivate
the players it's going to make the team
better than maybe it would have been
without all these issues that the team
has been dealing with am i right or am I
wrong
oh well I think only time will tell you
know I think we became closer maybe
because of everything throatier is a
mini camp it was it was it was fun to
see the guys you know coming to the
facility excited to be there excited to
to see each other the interactions and
the relationships you know they're all
been grateful for a great vibe within us
you know in our organization so we're
we're excited about the future man you
know I I know that running backs your
position not receiver but one of the big
questions with Antonio Brown gone can
juju Smith Schuster step into that role
where he's the number one guy who's
attracting extra attention
can he thrive with two maybe three guys
trying to stop what he's doing what do
you think
yes you know he's gonna be a lot of hope
we got Moncrief hegemons washington Ryan
Switzer Eli Rogers a lot of talented
guys you know so nobody has to do about
themselves so but no we seen juju it
seems like every other week he's going
for 97 in 99 yards you know these big
plays and just you know this being
productive week after week so he's more
than capable and he's gonna have a lot
of help so you know I'm excited for him
one of the more overlooked changes for
the Steelers this year James the
departure of offensive line coach Mike
Munchak how has that transition gone to
a new offensive line coach from Munchak
because he was so well respected did
such a good job there well Sean suite
stepped up you know he's already been
there with us and so on you know the old
line they already love him and had a
great relationship with them you know
when he was under coach Munchak so uh
you know I got a great relationship with
them too so it really don't feel like
much has changed no we missed much he's
a great person and great coach but you
know you know he's another situation so
we just gotta gotta move on
today's NFL presents a strange challenge
for running backs because on one hand
you want the ball you want to be the guy
you want to be the workhorse one you
want to prove you can carry the load and
wear defenses down on the other hand
teams like to have two maybe three guys
and you got Jalen Samuel you got Benny
snapping what's your preference because
sometimes if you burn too bright early
in your career you don't have that wear
and tear or you have too much wear and
tear and you can't extend your career
would you rather be the workhorse or do
you see some benefit in maybe having a
reduced load and playing deeper then
maybe you otherwise would yeah I
definitely see some benefits you know
from having a multiple talented guys you
know with special teams and you know
early on in the season as well you know
those guys are talented and so you know
there's no reason to you know that they
can make plays and so on you know
obviously one that when it's laying the
games on the line you know I want to be
the guy and you know make plays for us
but they're more than capable Jalen is a
great receiver Benny's a hard-nosed
runner great receiver as well so then
all we just gonna pull out from each
other man we just want to ring so I ever
thought you know our coaches and staff
make those decisions and and they've
been awesome so far
that will continue to be so we're
excited for if whatever's gonna get us a
ring that's what we gonna do James even
though we know it's old news that
Le'Veon Bell is gone Antonio Brown is
gone how do you keep that from becoming
a distraction during the season with
questions about hey what do you think of
how Antonio is doing in Oakland House
lady on Bell doing in New York how do
you guys wall that off shut that off and
not that let us let that affect what's
going on in your locker room I think we
bench set it off um you know we always
have respect for those guys those are
you know former teammates and they're
great people you know as well as
football players and stuff that's just
you know worried about what they're
doing in their other states and teams
that can help us none so you know we we
hope they do well and wish the best for
them but that can't help us at all so
you know that's that's been behind us
James before I let you go tell me more
about that vehicle that is sitting
behind you it looks like it's going 50
miles an hour and it's not even moving
tell me about it yeah man it's awesome
you do see they got the colors right on
this one too this is the black and
yellow one but man it's awesome the
slingshot you know three wheel roaster
it's been fun man it's the summer of fun
that's what we're doing and actually if
you go to Polaris slingshot calm you can
learn more about it go to the local
dealership take a test drive in it
that's each how to draw out a stick you
need is a regular driver's license and
you actually can win a free trip to
Hawaii I don't know what's better than
that just you know go take a test drive
into that contest you could be in Hawaii
checking a senior out in the roaster so
go check out Polaris slingshot calm you
won't so you pull up the training camp
in one of those in Latrobe at st.
Vincent's college what's mike tomlin
says think you think you'll like it you
know it's safe you know so you know it'd
be the only worry but I think us a sweet
ride you know
nice colors and everything so you know
it'll be cool well hey James
congratulations on all your success it's
been a great story and it's been fun to
watch and we look forward to seeing what
you do in 2019 buddy look forward to
talking to you down the road awesome
thank you brother
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports